a line has a slope of negative
three-fourths and goes to the point zero
comma eight what is the equation of this
line in slope intercept form slope
intercept form so any line can be
represented in slope intercept form is y
is equal to m
x plus b
where this m right over here that is the
slope of the line and this b over here
this is the y-intercept
y-intercept of the line let me draw
a quick line here just so that we can
visualize that a little bit so that is
my y-axis
and then that is my x-axis
my x-axis so let me draw a line and
since our line here has a negative slope
i'll draw a downward sloping line so
let's say our line looks something like
that
let's say it looks something like that
so hopefully we're a little familiar
with the slope already the slope
essentially tells us look start at some
point on the line
and go to some other point of the line
measure how much you have to move in the
x direction that is your run and then
measure how much you have to move in the
y direction that is your rise and our
slope is equal to rise
over
run and you can see over here it would
be downward sloping because if you move
in the positive x direction we have to
go down our run if our run is positive
our rise here is negative so this would
be a negative over a positive give you a
negative number and that makes sense
because we're downward sloping the more
we go down in this situation for every
step we move to the right the more
downward sloping will be the more of a
negative slope we'll have that's slope
so that slope right over here the
y-intercept just tells us where we
intercept the y-axis so the y-intercept
this point right over here this is where
the line intersects
intersects with the y axis this will be
the point zero
comma b and this actually just falls
straight out of this equation when x is
equal to zero so let's evaluate this
equation when x is equal to zero y will
be equal to m
times zero
plus b well anything times zero is zero
so y is equal to zero plus b or y will
be equal to b when x is equal to zero
when x is equal to zero when
when x is equal to zero so this is the
point zero comma b
now they tell us what the slope of this
line is they tell us a line has a slope
of negative three-fourths so we know
that our slope is negative three-fourths
and they tell us that the line goes
through the point zero comma eight
they tell us we go through that let me
just in a new color i've already used
orange let me use this green color they
tell us that we go through the point
zero comma eight notice x is zero so
we're on the y axis when x is zero we're
on the y axis so this is our y-intercept
so b
we could say we could do the couples our
y-intercept is the point zero comma
eight or we could say that b remember
it's also zero comma b we could say b is
equal to eight so we know m is equal to
negative three-fourths b is equal to
eight so we can write the equation of
this line in slope-intercept form it's y
is equal to
negative three-fourths
negative three-fourths
times x
times x plus b plus eight
plus eight and we are done
we are done